we're learning more about the 64
year-old suspect Steven paddock his
brother Eric who was shown on the left
in this picture lives in the Orlando
area mark layman of our affiliate WKMG
spoke to him this morning
Eric paddock says he feels like an
asteroid has hit his family he has no
police record
yes he doesn't even have parking tickets
probably there's this is how did you
hear we got phone calls that Las Vegas
PD we're calling operating with the cops
we have talked to the PD we this is like
you called me up and said your next-door
neighbor did this and I go I've ever
seen him do is mow his yard the fact
that my brother did this is there's no
there's nothing I mean there's
absolutely no public record stuff
there's not even anything I can say I
mean how do you I mean my brother did
this I this is like it was done you know
like he shot us
I mean if he'd had killed my kids I
couldn't be more dumbfounded I mean it
doesn't there's nothing the techs he
said you know how's mom did you get
power you know I mean that was it
there's absolutely we have nothing like
I said we have nothing for you
I mean I hope someone finds out it
figures out because I we'd like to know
you real close family you guys you know
I think the good sign if he's checking
on your mom I live here
he lives in Mesquite once again public
records stuff you'll find out I mean I
live here he lives we're not that close
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the fact that he had those kind of
weapons is just where the hell did he
get automatic weapons he's not he has no
military background anything like that I
mean he's a guy who lived in a house in
Mesquite drove down and gambled in Las
Vegas he did stuff burritos
was the woman that they were looking for
his girlfriend yes yeah Mary Lou I mean
that's why I was on the phone with the
cops because I I mean I worried he might
have hurt her - links are actually
describing her as his wife do so you
they might have got married but I don't
think they're married he's just his
girlfriend what do you know about her
she's a nice lady I've met her three or
four times she's got a Facebook page she
sends cookies to my mom I mean no he
doesn't have any children or anything
Yeah right
there's nothing you know I mean we're
just it's like you think it's a Geo
except that it came in all five of my
phones in the house and the cells and
everything lit up at the same time you
know I'd have thought it was one of my
friends joking but I mean when you get a
phone call that says your brother you
know just killed a bunch of people this
is not
[Music]
people stay at least on the sidewalk I'm
answering
I mean we're answering the phone and
talking to random people but we're
telling them we're gonna put out a like
a five line statement that says what
I've just told you that we're shocked
horrified completely dumbfounded